I think the nice thing is people who are
looking at nutrition now and saying wait
a minute maybe they weren't right about
that either you know as we're seeing the
sort of the push to the plant-based diet
and even the insect-based diet insects
are disgusting for a reason one of the
things I tell people is climate has
changed I have no way of really
determine that myself I can't walk
outside so it looks like the climate's
changing because it's raining or it's
snowing or it's got hot I can't do that
but what I can do is I can look in the
mirror and I can say hey look I feel
better I I you know everything is better
for me and no one can hide that
no amount of gas lining is going to make
me not understand that I'm out there I
think this becomes a value
[Music]
this episode of the podcast was
sponsored by better fed beef
the company that has saved me from just
eating lamb lamb was easier on my
stomach because I can't tolerate aged
meat so I ate lamb for two years on the
lion diet which I did because it's
easier to be healthy than it is to eat
yummy things health is always easier
than eating yummy things but wow is beef
so much better than lamb this cattle
farming company better fed produces
extremely consistent and tender beef if
you've had trouble finding great beef in
the past your Search is Over better
fed's cattle Farms are managed by 17
different families across the Midwest
who love and personally care for the
cattle themselves better fed beef has
the best tasting beef I have tried out
of a box and I have tried a lot of them
probably most of them over the last five
years of doing this diet most of them
you need to get variety when you can on
this diet so trying different companies
is my variety better fed are by far my
favorite they have an insane number of
options to choose from like the Backyard
Barbecue Box Tomahawk rib eyes whole
muscle Ground Beef skirt steaks ribs and
a lot more even if you're not on the
lion diet or the carnivore diet everyone
can get healthier by eating more
and this is great tasting beef why would
you not eat it my listeners can get 25
off their first order which is crazy by
going to betterfedbeef.com and using
promo code MP at checkout their
website's betterfedbeef.com these guys
are the bomb diggity I hope you enjoy
this episode
[Music]
Dr Sean Baker welcome back to my podcast
thanks it's good to be back good to see
you again glad to see you doing so well
yeah thank you I am doing well it it's
good a huge part of that is because of
diet most of that is because of diet but
before we get into that can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what is it is you do for anybody who's
not familiar with who you are well yeah
my name is Dr Sean Baker I am by
training and orthopedic surgeon uh about
10 years ago I got interested in diet
nutrition for my own personal reasons uh
sought a lot of benefits you know tried
different variations of very different
all kinds of different diets ended up
with a low carb diet
um at one point I went on a ketogenic
diet started to see a lot of
improvements on patients that I was
trying it on that had various Orthopedic
conditions and seemed to help
significantly with joint pain eventually
I uh you know discovered a group of
people that were doing an all-meat diet
and I started doing that myself even as
crazy as sounds this is about a little
over six years ago and um
you know if you wrote a book called the
carnivore I'd actually name this thing
the carnivore died you know what before
it was called the cereal carb diet I
think and I've been eating you know
basically it pretty much a only diet or
very close to it for the last uh six
plus years and uh you know I've been
been basically an advocate for for meat
in the diet and we've seen you know as
you know thousands and thousands of
people now that the result all sorts of
health issues you know whether it's
autoimmune conditions whether it's gut
issues whether it's arthritis whether
it's mental health issues you know
diabetes on and on and on so that's been
where I'm at I am the co-founder of a
company called Rivero and our mission is
to reverse chronic disease get people
off meds and we are you know just at the
point where we're scaling up and having
a long success with that so that's kind
of me and I'm you know in a quick
overview
okay amazing so uh as you know the the
reason that I was comfortable switching
on to a meat diet is somebody sent me
your episode with
uh Joe Rogan many years ago and I had I
was at the point where I was eating like
meat and lettuce but I hadn't dropped
the lettuce because I had like at that
point I was breastfeeding and I thought
the lettuce was what was giving me the
vitamins I like I needed it's like at
least I have some plant in my diet and
it wasn't working for me and I was
arthritic and depressed and I was itchy
everywhere and I couldn't get my
symptoms under control and it was just
like oh yeah well there's this doctor
he's been doing it for years and it was
like that day where I was like okay good
like if that's doable then I'll try it
and so I'm coming up on five years of
just eating ruminant meat which is part
of the reason I had you back on five
years time flies
so alive look at that you haven't
dropped in as Kirby or anything it's
amazing no I haven't and so I thought we
could talk a little bit about what
you're doing with your company
um and also cover some carnivore basics
for anybody who's
looking to get started and just needs a
little push
um but I think first what exactly is
Rivero and what are you trying to do
with it yeah so we are a digital
Healthcare company uh you know our goal
is to basically take people that are
sick that are you know like you know as
opposed to the normal Health Care System
you go and you're sick and most of the
time you come out with some sort of
medication maybe you get a procedure and
that's that's sort of the Paradigm that
we've been in now for the last you know
30 40 years in medicine and I think it's
medicine is strayed away from its
original course it's now become really
just a big business and it's really kind
of a
you know kind of a subcontractor for for
the pharmaceutical industry I mean most
Physicians you know they did get all the
training based you know from
pharmaceutical companies that wrote a
lot of the curriculums
um we know we we found as you know I
mean there's ways to get people off
medications and actually to in many
cases reverse the diseases and so that's
our mission so everybody works for us
all our providers know from the
beginning that is the goal the goal is
to get these people off medications get
them truly healthy as opposed to what
normally might happen and so we you know
we are you know we have a team of
software Engineers we have health care
providers we have you know coaches one
of the problems a lot of Physicians face
is you know maybe they want to try
lifestyle but they don't really they're
not really supported in that there's no
uh there's no sort of mechanism by which
to get people you know the facilities
and the resources they need and so we're
going to be that and so all of our
physicians are on board uh they're not
afraid of people eating meat uh in many
cases they'll encourage that and so
that's what we're doing uh you know we
raised quite a bit of money and quite a
bit of capital initially from crowd
equity and then also kind of venture
capital money from that so our goal
right now is you know we're we'll later
that this you know well later this year
early next year we'll start opening in
several States and then the goal
eventually will be Nationwide and
hopefully globally uh within a few years
so that is kind of the overview
yeah cool congratulations
thanks yeah wow that's huge uh that
would have been very helpful back in the
day
yeah if I heard of it yeah yeah no that
that's uh that's fantastic okay so
people listening if they decide they
want to give it a shot and they want
some guidance that's a place you can go
to learn more about the diet yeah that's
cool it's also important because a lot
of people are on medications you know
you need a position to decrescribe
medications and you know a lot of a lot
of the people coming off medications can
potentially run into trouble you know if
they come off yeah diabetic matter and
hypertensive matter you know psychiatric
meds you know you have to wean them
accessibly and yeah
you can't you know go to campus to hey
stop taking your meds because that's
considered uh the practice of medicine
so we have we have to set this up in the
system uh you know follow all the
regulatory rules that are in place and
so but you know you do need a physician
support because a lot of people as you
know they go on a carnivore diet their
physician doesn't support them they tell
them yeah
you know the funny thing is you know a
lot of people say well why is it so bad
we'll say well you know you might be
increasing your risk for heart disease
and you say what are all your other
patients die of it's like well heart
disease so it's like you know why why
you know I've improved my quality of
life I've you know gotten off all these
medications I feel significantly better
and you're telling me I should stop
because I might die of the same thing
that everybody else died of I mean it's
just kind of crazy in my view but anyway
it's crazy and as you know and you I
know you've been maligned as I have you
know so you didn't really have
rheumatoid arthritis or you didn't have
these things walking around with a hip
replacement or a vision knee or a vision
ankle rather than like of course you did
yeah but you know when you have support
and including physician support the
likelihood of you being successful goes
up tremendously and so we want to
provide that support support for people
that want to do something like this and
just to be clear Rivera was not going to
be strictly carnivore if there's going
to be people there's going to be
different sort of nutritional therapies
depending upon what the actual uh
position person's circumstances you know
and we were using a lot of these
powerful uh artificial intelligence
algorithms to help figure that out
because we've got lots and lots of data
on that have done these elimination
diets reintroduced stuff we see some
people can do this safely some people
can and it's really cool
the individual person and the unique
conditions are different
that's fantastic that's fantastic
because when I first went on the paleo
diet and it was very restrictive paleo
diet but it had cut you know everything
processed all grains nuts it included
including eggs and dairy just anything
that I thought I could be allergic to I
actually was in remission on that diet
until
I had a reaction and took a bunch of
medication and had a pregnancy and
whatever that combination of
reintroducing medications again and the
pregnancy then the paleo diet stopped
working for me
I think that's that's interesting
because you know you do see these
different conditions so Michaela
pre-pregnancy was different than
Michaela post-pregnancy yeah technology
has changed and therefore maybe your
nutrition changes that's some of the
things we can figure out which I think
is kind of neat and the nice thing again
with the AI it's adaptive and so as we
did more and more data we can get more
and more precise with with what we do
and so that's you know like if somebody
says hey you told me I could do this
this and this and one of those things
didn't work you plug that back in the
algorithm you find out what's actually
unique about that person you get more
data and you refine it so as time goes
by we get better and better which is
nice
yeah that's great that's very helpful
um when I was trying to figure out what
I was like allergic to or sensitive to I
had everything typed into a spreadsheet
and it was a lot there's a lot of
information there and I wasn't I wasn't
a robot so yeah
it simplifies it you know because it can
be very complicated when you're dealing
with literally thousands of food choices
uh most people can't figure that out
never do and that's why I think there
was the ultimate Elimination Diet and
like you said like you and I both know
it's sustainable over the long term if
you want to do it for years and years
go forward that's fine it works
cool okay
um so for people who are considering
getting started and have concerns like
um
well first of all I guess if you have a
doctor that's saying don't do this
because your cholesterol is going to go
up and all these problems you can always
switch your doctors and Rivera there's a
platform with doctors who can probably
communicate with you better but for
people who are still in that position
um what's what's your opinion on the
carnivore diet and raising cholesterol
well I don't think ignoring cholesterol
and saying it's always fine if it goes
up I think that's that's not correct
either I think there's some Nuance there
and one of the things is you know we can
say that you know elevated particularly
April B which is the sort of the
you know item of concern if it goes up
significantly then that is an
independent risk factor for heart
disease however when we look at things
that are in meat you know like like meat
is mostly monounsaturated fat and he has
all these other compounds carnitine
carnosine creatine taurine all which
have been shown to decrease risk of
cardiovascular disease in fact there was
just a study came out last week in the
European Journal prevented Cardiology
we're getting saturated fat and so
there's really no evidence they looked
at all the evidence out there rcts you
know
prospective epidemiology cohort studies
on and on and on and they said there's
really no real evidence of saturated if
that leads to an increase in
cardiovascular disease and you know Mi
Strokes any of that stuff and so I think
I think generally
um if you go on a diet and you tend to
lose weight and you get healthier and
all your markers come down and we see
that often you know the blood glucose
normalizes
the inflammatory markers known as you
know we hear from sort of the
plant-based cancer inflammatory meat is
but you and I adults know it's anything
but it decreases inflammation
significantly we know that you know
inflation does play role in the heart
disease and so
um certainly uh you know relative to
what everyone else is eating which is
you know most of the people are eating
the standard American diet which is
mostly processed food according to an
all mean diet in my view and I think the
evidence of reports that is going to
largely decrease your risk for
cardiovascular disease even even if it
does increase your LDL cholesterol now
uh you know with those other factors in
there you can and I and I tell people
you know hey go get more information
find out what what type of LDL you're
dealing with is it oxidized is it large
which is a small particle
um are there other things that are going
on you know is there a net effect none
of the Imaging is really good so if
you're after if you're older than 40
years of age you can get some of those
Advanced Imaging you know coronary
calcium scans the angiographies and
things like that so you can just kind of
monitor things time goes by so you
shouldn't ignore it but at the same time
I mean
I mean I would even tell you I mean
Mikhail you can answer this question if
somebody said Michaela you you've
increased your risk for heart disease by
20 by going on this you know crazy need
only diet and you should stop and go
back to the quality of life you had
before what would you say I mean even
knowing you're at increased risk I'm
guessing you're saving it away right oh
yeah no well I would say something else
was going to kill me a lot faster even
if I met a theoretic increased risk plus
I feel fine yeah but I'm super skeptical
about anything now it's like no you can
judge how you're feeling yeah I mean I
mean and the skepticism you know we you
know all of us have just come to the
last couple years with this pandemic and
we've seen a lot of yeah uh you know uh
hypo hypocrisy a lot of you know change
in our mind maybe we got it right maybe
we didn't
and you know we're seeing all the
background now and it gives you a sort
of a a sense of hey maybe these people
don't know what the hell they're doing
and they're you know some that they're
kind of making up
and you know you look at that and you
see and you can see where that's
happened in many many other occasions I
think the nice thing is people are
looking at nutrition now and saying wait
a minute maybe they were right about
that either you know as we're seeing the
uh uh the the sort of the push to the
plant-based diet and even the
insect-based diet which you know I mean
I think it's it's insects are disgusting
for a reason
you know I don't like to eat them and
it's just one of those things they want
to push on us so yes I think we should
be skeptical you know
you know and look at them and you take
things matters on your own in your own
hands and objectively assess things you
can look in the mirror I mean gosh you
know one of the things I tell people is
you know I can't you know I don't know
climate has changed I have no way to
really determine that myself I can't
walk outside so it looks like the
climate's changing because it's Rainier
it's snowing or it's got hot I can't do
that but what I can do is I can look in
the mirror and I can say hey look I feel
better I I you know everything is better
for me and no one can hide that for me
you know no amount of gas lining is
going to uh make me not understand that
I'm healthier right and I think that's I
think that's that's a valid way to do
that
yeah
um for transition symptoms from people
going from say the standard American
diet over to the carnivore diet what is
it that you've seen happens to people
well I mean certainly you know if you're
eating a you know sort of standard
American diet lots of carbohydrates and
you go to a carport which is you know
very little to no carbohydrates you're
going to see some relative you know loss
of fluid you know we're going to see you
know our insulin levels tend to fall a
little bit and that causes the kidneys
to no longer hang on to sodium water so
you end up you know become a relatively
dehydrated uh you know particularly in
the transition so some people will
recommend increasing fluid and
electrolyte uh your bowel movement
frequency is going to most likely change
you're now eating food that is now very
bioavailable and highly absorbed so
you're just not making as much waste
product system you'll see adults
decrease frequency in bowel movements
and some people say oh my God I'm
constipated that's usually not the case
it's just that you don't have as much
waste to get rid of them uh those are
typically I think some people you know
notice a change in their sleep patterns
um I find that you know one of the
things that you know I've come to
discover over the years is you know
particularly if you're eating big large
protein-based meal at night it can
interfere with sleep you know
particularly because you just have to
deal with the nitrogen from the protein
and you you know the way we deal with
that is excreting it through you know
your substance called urea and we have
to breathe it out we sweat it out we
have to urinate and so those things can
interfere with sleep a little bit to
expect be mindful of that
um but really those are the major things
that we see some people energy I think
one of the biggest things that a lot of
people tend to underneath because meat
is so satiating yeah I did that yeah
long term Society so you tend to under
eat and so you have to realize
um if you're particularly if you're
losing a lot of weight and you're tired
and fatigued you just have to sort of
maybe just uh force yourself to eat a
little bit more
that that's a that's a good piece of
advice
um when I first started the diet
yeah my Hunger cues were completely
disorganized and that was from going
from like a Paleo and then a keto diet
so I was eating very clean for a number
of years before I went to carnivore and
when I switched over to carnivore
um first by like day three I was just
absolutely repulsed by the idea of only
eating meat even though I had been
eating steak and salad every meal right
so day three I was like nauseated I
didn't want to touch meat and I think I
had a rougher transition than some
people I've talked to a lot of people
and they're like oh yeah wow week one
and I feel a lot better but I think
because I had an autoimmune disorder and
like there was a lot going on I didn't
feel great I had like my digestion was
in rough shape
um like I had diarrhea at the beginning
um I had muscle cramps around month five
that just so after I got over the
transition period around six weeks I
felt quite a bit better and at month
five I hadn't started getting muscle
cramps and this is before I knew that
you could kind of play around with
sodium and potassium and magnesium
levels and I just dealt with it I was
like nah I'm not introducing anything
I'm just gonna wait and I had Wicked
muscle cramps for like a month and a
half maybe two months off and on at
night which I think could have been
fixed with the introduction of
electrolytes but I didn't know anything
about that I was also drinking way too
much water at the beginning I was
unbelievably thirsty so I was drinking
like and I didn't Maybe
maybe like four or five bottles of water
my dad had a similar problem where he
was just excessively thirsty like I
couldn't get enough water which I think
was also screwing up my electrolytes it
was it was hard for me to adapt to it I
wasn't I was under eating and then I was
overeating so I was eating three steaks
a day which is too much for me
um and I was like because I was having
carb withdrawal so I was craving food
but it wasn't hunger it was cravings and
I was trying to fill that it was tricky
switching over and that was just from
dropping salad which seems ridiculous
like that seems like the last step but
it was tricky well yeah I mean you
thought about you know drinking water
you know water obviously you need water
to hydrate but you need to accompany
that with the electrolytes because
otherwise once you start to electrolytes
in your body your body just gets really
extra water and so it's hard to catch up
with this you have to include a little
bit of electrolyte in there yeah that
that often cramping is something that we
do occasionally see from from people and
you know often it's you know figuring
out an electrolyte fluid electrolyte
balance is usually what cures that
sometimes people are under eating when
they see that over exercising underneath
not picking in enough calories or fat
and those things about commonly see with
cramping but it generally tends to
transition away for most people
I mean it went away for me and I didn't
even change anything it was like so I
just suffered it's like wow my leg's
really going at it tonight that hope
that stops at some point
it's not fun it can be painful
yeah quite painful yeah
um okay what have you seen for uh you
must deal with people who have a whole
host of disorders so what would you say
the average person who comes to you
could you like Define what they look
like
well I mean gosh at this point there's a
wide variety of professional athletes
you know I do consultations still you
know uh you know Monday through Friday
for an hour a day so I get all kinds of
I get a lot of X you know believe it or
not a whole bunch of ex-we against I
mean I you know 10 20 30 or X vegans
that come in that have just eventually
just
found it just didn't work for them uh
you know obviously a lot of people with
weight loss issues are common you know
obesity is becoming so common so you
know half the population has it so we
see that pretty frequently I see a lot
of people again with autoimmune
conditions I see a lot of particularly
women with things like hypothyroidism uh
we see
um definitely a not insignificant number
of people that have uh primer gut issues
like IBS or
the more severe things like you know
Crohn's disease or also colitis those
things to come in very frequently
rheumatoid arthrit psoriasis and other
real common one which
karma not very effectively treats in
many many cases a lot of mental health
issues you know we have a lot of people
depression anxiety
bipolar disordering things like PTSD
that are being you know are improved
with the diet in some cases you know
completely put in remission so it's been
you know it's been I think in general
good nutrition pretty much fixes just
about everything at least when it comes
to chronic diseases and so it just makes
sense and it plays such a significant
role in creating the diseases and we've
got as we see uh it doesn't take anyone
long to figure out if you go out in
public you see so many people that are
just you're all sick and everybody
around you is now sick and it's hard to
find a healthy person these days and
it's because we're all eating the same
kind of what you do once you once you
eliminate that a lot of things get
better
yeah yeah it's wild
um it's interesting too for things like
PTSD it's something that somebody with
PTSD might not consider something like
nutrition playing a role right
especially if you're traumatized from
experiences that are traumatizing
but I know I had I had PTSD from a
couple of Hospital experiences and then
some health issues with my family and
it comes back a bit especially with the
experience getting my dad off of
psychiatric medications which was just
like literally almost killed him it was
horrifying and uh that was very
traumatizing
and I've managed to deal with that
because of the diet and if I have a
reaction to something I still do have
reactions to something if I accidentally
eat something that isn't carnivore my
anxiety skyrockets and those memories
come back and I have a difficult time
sleeping and everything but if I'm on
the diet they're not there so I would
urge anybody who's suffering from PTSD
that's like actually caused by traumatic
experiences to consider the role of
nutrition because if you're in a calmer
State those memories might not be as
haunting this episode is sponsored by
nordvpn if you're listening to this you
are probably some of the most
well-informed and least paranoid people
on the planet but are you too nonchalant
about your safety what about your data
do you have the same mindset when it
comes to keeping your internet
connection secure it's not paranoia if
everyone's really out to get you the
main thing about using a VPN is if
you're downloading content and you don't
want to be caught you don't have to be
paranoid that you'll go to jail because
of some archaic law when you're doing so
just use nordvpn your internet service
provider also can apparently sell your
data to advertisers for a profit all
while forfeiting the idea that people
like you have a right to own their
online information you can defend your
online privacy by grabbing nordvpn they
have a great deal at nordvpn.com
tmpp or use promo code tmpp for 61 off
their Premium plan and their free
anti-malware feature all with nordvpn's
30-day money-back guarantee I hope you
enjoy the rest of this episode
yeah I think it's good advice and I yeah
it's it's you know it's kind of funny
there was no way that I could affect pts
it actually does I mean there's you know
there's brain physiology going on in
your diet impacts everything and I've
seen a number of people with PTSD it
doesn't change the fact that the trauma
has occurred you still have to deal with
that for other means but at least
putting yourself in a better physiologic
state so you aren't so reactive
um and you know you have a little bit
more sense of calmness
um does clearly help
mm-hmm
um and then for people switching on to
it do you recommend they go from the
standard American diet directly onto the
carnivore diet or do you do a weaning
process or is it dependent on the person
I mean yeah a little bit's gonna depend
on the person you know I think that you
know I can make an argument for why
weaning might make sense because you
know some people particularly some of
these on a bunch of medications and sick
and if you rapidly drop that they may
have some pretty severe uh transition
symptoms enough to where they don't want
to do it because they feel so bad and so
I think in those cases uh you know
somebody's already been on a low carb or
ketogenic style diet ahead of time that
may generally can just drop right into
it but somebody who's like you said on
this High car you know junk food based
standard American diet then they may
find just reducing some of the some of
the sugar the grain you know the
processed foods first maybe maybe
transitioning low carbs increasing uh
the the high quality nutrition steak and
eggs and things like that in the diet
and then they're going to tapering down
why are we taking on the carbohydrates
over you know four or six week period
often makes it a little bit easier for
them to do and you know there's other
people on the other hand that are you
know have this severe problem with the
way they relate to food you know some
people call them addicts to sugary food
processed food junk food whatever
you know they can't be moderators or
some people that can moderate food and
many people can't you know they just you
can't give them a piece of chocolate and
they'll eat them all I can't bar and six
you know six pints of ice cream
afterwards so you gotta get your money
yeah
what were you like before the carnivore
diet I couldn't regulate I couldn't
regulate at all it was crazy I didn't
understand how people could go to a
party and have like one piece of pizza
or something and that stuff was killing
me like I had celiac disease and it was
like it was it was awful I think part of
it was a side effect from the ssris I
think that increased my appetite but
even after that it was like I get
Cravings like crazy if I eat something
accidentally like if I'm at a restaurant
and I get hit with something now all the
Cravings come back it's wild so I wasn't
a regulator yeah I pretty much wasn't
I'm having a big big human being I've
seen at some point six five 230 pounds
or 300 pounds and I could eat a lot of
regularly nine thousand calories and I
prefer so for me to eat a pint of my ice
cream that was an appetizer are usually
three or four of them and you know I did
a Whole Foods maybe three four you know
entrees at dinner so I I was always some
of the day a lot and now I mean I can I
have much better appetite control I'm
still you know a large person but
um I uh I I don't you know the satiety
that I get from just basically eating me
and like you I feel best on just me when
I'm just pure ready I do include some
eggs and a little bit of dairy from here
and there in my diet these days but
anytime I wanna you know like I just
want to tighten things up and feel
better I'll just go straight to straight
up red meat and that to me is is the
home base it's a place where I feel the
best
cool cool
okay
um how how do you feel about
incorporating organs or supplements on
the diet
uh well I mean you know and this is
something I know there's a lot of people
out there talking about the essentiality
of organs and things like that I mean I
don't personally I don't use organ means
I don't take organic supplements I
haven't for you know uh the whole time
I've been doing I mean I've tried some
more roommates I just don't prefer them
I don't think they taste very good in my
view
other people are you know other people
like them uh the data that we have you
know the Harvard University study that
came out in 2021 showed that organs
provided no additional benefit when it
came to preventing nutrient deficiencies
uh or symptoms of those uh the study I
had I collected data on 12 000 people
doing the car there's no difference in
outcomes across the board wow those
included supplements or organs versus
those that did not so I don't think the
argument can be made but broadly
everyone needs to be taking these things
now I will tell you that there are
individuals to say I just feel a little
better when I include this or that uh
Oregon me typically I think you know if
you're going to give this detail
ornaments don't waste your money on the
supplements are overpriced in my view uh
and so you're kind of getting ripped off
a little bit
um I think that uh
you know many people you know it depends
I guess you're coming from a background
where you're extremely extremely
nutrient poor you know you've got all
these sort of chronic deficiencies
organies can be a way to say to sort of
bring those things back up but then most
people they do this diet long term I'm
talking you know many many years
generally routinely don't include
organization this is what you know I
learned when I first started this from
people they've been doing it for 10 or
plus years 20 years on and like you know
a lot of people come and go they start
out they think they immediate all the
organ needs to do that for a while and
then they either quit the diet and go
out and do something else and go back to
doing it Omniverse diet and there's some
people that think that the organ means
actually for some people depending how
much you're consuming can actually be a
net negative uh so I don't think they're
necessary I don't tell people not to eat
them what I say you know if you like
them try them you know include them you
know when you want to but to sit there
and think you have to have them to be
healthy or quote-unquote optimal
I don't think the data supports that
I think it's confusing for people
because you get on a diet where well if
you're told you need all these different
foods to fulfill all your vitamin needs
and then you switch over to just eating
steak it's like okay well that can't
possibly fulfill everything maybe maybe
liver gives me a bit of variety and then
maybe I get some vitamins that I'm
missing well you know it's it's
interesting because you know like a lot
of people like this modern carnivore
movement can trace its roots in a lot of
cases they're having staphon or Wilma
stefans and who you know Canadian
Explorer spent all this time up in you
know up in the Arctic with with the the
Inuit and he basically stated he's like
the only thing you need is red meat and
made enough that he said the organ Meats
were things that we generally gave to
the dogs in many cases not that they
weren't sometimes eating them but he
said they weren't necessary and he lived
up there for these guys for I think a
collective of 12 years and so this is
you know from from the beginning uh I
don't think you need them I mean I don't
use them and I'm not dead I'm you know
like I said just I'm I literally just
taught you know
is ranked number one in the world and
again on on rowing you know hey
congratulations I mean that's huge so I
mean I'm you know I'm doing well I'm
doing fine I don't need to include those
things in the diet so I think it's
something that you know they're they're
like I said uh I mean I can understand
the the sort of the narrative you know
talk about all these tribal people would
eat this but you know you look at who
you're comparing it to most of these you
know modern-day indigenous tribes are
still around the ones we've had contact
with in the last you know 100 years or
so they're really poor and they're
really living on the fringes and they're
living in a subsistence existence and so
they got to eat everything they can come
across whereas early humans it can be
argued we're living in a time of uh
Surplus and so there are lots of big
animals around there literally millions
and millions of these
giant you know Mega herbivores you know
elephants and mastodons and giant these
other giant animals and we were good at
killing them so we probably had lots and
lots of me you think about if it if it
how do we grow this big big brain from
this little tiny thing that these uh you
know our previous you know predecessors
the arthropistacenes in an early uh
humans you know like homo have lists of
our brains continue to grow and grow
that's because we had constant access to
high quality nutrient dense calorie
dense foods and this would be you know
large animals that's a large animal fat
yeah yeah I love that
um I didn't I don't eat liver and
neither do my parents so my parents have
been on the diet now I started December
2017. my mom started in January she
hopped on board right away she's really
opened okay I'll do it too and then my
dad was a bit harder to convince he's
like what I also have to drop salad like
what I'm only eating salad it's really
the salad I was like yeah sorry it's
probably the salad
um but I think we're also like hyper
hyper sensitive from being on medication
for years like I I really do think the
ssris sensitized my brain to carbs when
I went off of them so I was on the paleo
diet everything got better and I went
off of all my medication and uh you
shouldn't do that
you should definitely not do that for
ssris or psych meds and I got light
senses light sensitivity and Sound
Sensitivity and touch sensitivity and
temperature sensitivity like my my
entire nervous system just was on fire
and uh and then I my reactions to Foods
were just it was horrible it was like
pain
um I hallucinated a number of times it
was it was on another level of bad and I
don't think they would have been that
severe without being on ssris
particularly through my developmental
period like 10 years I don't know if you
saw McAlister's the paper just came out
showing that uh you know the the whole
premise of ssris was based on the
thought that there was this imbalance of
serotonin in the brain it turns out that
wasn't even true so you know how many
people
maybe that mechanism was completely made
up or not based on good data
so it's kind of interesting to see that
but yeah you're correct a lot of these
uh different uh psychiatric medications
it's it's a problem if you're just
trying to completely you can run into
big problems
yeah yeah big problems I didn't know
that at all at the time anyway I know
now so that was fun
um okay so what's your plan with Rivero
in the future do you have goals is it
just to spread around awareness well I
mean our goal is you know to to grow
into a sizable company you know a
significant alternative to the standard
allopathic thing allopathic system and
we have uh you know there's several
other companies out there that are doing
sort of kind of similar things I think
were unique in the way we we you know
deal with nutrition our goal is to be a
very large company a multi-billion
dollar company a company that takes care
of
you know hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people you know around the
United States around the world
you know and hopefully to turn this
thing around and we haven't we have this
you know looming and so well I mean I
would argue that we're already there but
we have this chronic disease Health Care
crisis in this country without getting
better we're just continuing your worth
our life expectancy is going down and
the prevalence of chronic disease
continues to go up the Obesity rates
continue to go up something has to be
done and so we're going to be part of
that solution and I think you know I
mean so I mean obviously we're going to
be taking care of patients but the other
aspect of this is you know because the
question is well there's no money in
meeting people healthy we often hear
that but I think there is and I think
what we
um uh find is that when you partner with
other companies you know let's say you
go to a large corporation say like Ford
Motor Company or something and they're
spending a significant amount of their
costs go to health care for their
employees and you can dramatically cut
that in you know down you know as we see
we have people ah
you know multi-thousand dollar a month
infusions for autoimmune disease and you
get rid of those things and make these
people not need that that dramatically
save money for these companies so these
companies are incentivized financially
uh to do this not only for their own
bottom dollar or their bottom line but
also for the health and the productivity
of their employees so the employees feel
better the company's saving more money
so there isn't you know you take it away
from Pharma you know they're not going
to be happy about this but you know
other companies are going to see the net
benefit so we move some of that money
from farmer profits into uh maybe other
corporations profits and their
productivity and things that arguably
would be better for society I think you
know the less people that we have that
are medicated
the better you know
yeah that's for sure that's actually a
very good point
that that there actually is a a need for
this just in regards to money that is a
good point because people do talk about
the pharmacy pharmaceutical companies
and how much they make and they're not
incentivized but yeah companies are
incentivized I like that that's good and
employees are probably going to be more
productive if they're not stuck on a
whole bunch of medication
topics on your show where one person
disagrees and we have a lot of you know
and it's cordial we have a lot of uh
Angry Angry people out there they're
really mad at each other they're mad at
life in general they're generally
unhappy and I think nutrition plays
actually a big role in it you know when
you're when you're feeling bad and hurt
and in pain you're just in a bad mood
all the time we have so many people are
in bad moods and when you when you go
car I don't know about you but I'm
generally just kind of happy and chilled
out and that's my Baseline State as
opposed to this you know this Rapid
Cycling management between rage and you
know Superman and so now everybody's
just happy and chilled out
um I think Society in general is better
I mean
cooperate we can do things to to to you
know the Beautiful Things humans are
capable of you know and making all these
great things rather than just constantly
fighting at each other which I think is
it's it's depressing to see a lot you
know little people yeah it's
heartbreaking it's also like you you
have no idea what type of person who's
currently suffering from a chronic
illness what they'd be capable of if
they were healthy right like if they're
not struggling to survive it's it's
heartbreaking and especially when this
diet can help
can help so quickly even if you go on a
medication right with a chronic illness
they go okay well usually it's like six
weeks right to see some sort of result
and for people with autoimmunity going
on immune suppressants they're like well
this isn't it it's not a cure maybe you
can achieve a medically induced
remission but it's not like the damage
stops right yeah and and the other costs
I mean so I mean you're only if you're
on immune modulating drug I mean your
immune system is being compromised so
now you're more susceptible cancer
you're more so susceptible to infections
and other young babies GI side there's
all kinds of side effects that come with
these things and you know it's like I'm
trading one side effect the other and
I'm pretty myself at increased risk
whereas diet generally doesn't have
those things and you know just just
fixing your nutrition in general whether
it's Carnival or something else
has a big role and I think we should I
don't know why we're not screaming that
from the rooftops you know for every
chronic disease including you know like
this pandemic we just went through we
probably would have suffered way less uh
morbidity and mortality had we sort of
said hey look we need more people that
just take this is a good time to maybe
get off all the processed food
uh and why we didn't do that to me is
still I mean it's really kind of
very disappointing
yeah well it's hard to like I think you
have to be pretty driven to take it into
your own hands and to start removing
foods from your diet especially if you
have
Cravings towards them like um I've I
don't think everybody
can do it and I mean if people around
them were doing it and there was more
kind of societal recognition and their
doctor was saying oh you should do it
then maybe those people would be pushed
but I think some people have a really
hard time removing like good yummy food
well and you know it's kind of
interesting I had someone who you know
met with me the other day asked if they
could work for my company and I said
what's the motivation there she said
I've been a chemical engineer working
for the food industry and my job was to
make food addictive to people and I no
longer no longer can your conscious do
this job anymore it's it's I've seen the
damage I've done and so clearly I mean
the food is literally engineered to me
and you know ultimately these people get
very sick eating that and now we have
people talking about you know I see this
it's kind of crazy now we have people
actually advocating that you know
there's no such thing as bad food and
you know you can't have a healthy
relationship with food by by saying some
foods are bad when clearly some foods
aren't bad for us I mean these Ultra
processed
really just you know junk latent foods
which provide really no benefit on
outside of the hedonistic pleasure are
clearly causing health problems and you
see these people with you know massive
obesity more obesity out they're saying
well there's nothing wrong with being
obese which is also a problem I mean
when you have that attitude and that's
being pushed forward on one of these
poor uh vulnerable people that just say
well I'm I'm going to be obese there's
nothing I can do about it and therefore
I should Revel just continue to get
sicker and sicker and that's a real it's
a real problem
yeah
um how do you feel about people who say
okay well
um okay let me let me preface this
um Scarlett doesn't eat processed foods
or sugar right and she's in kindergarten
now so she went to school and
um she's at Camp actually and they were
making some sort of like cookie mix at
Camp which I probably would have just
pulled her out because if you don't eat
cookies just kind of torture having a
kid make cookies like
but I didn't know that was going on
anyway she ate some of the cookie dough
which is something she hasn't had before
and she came back and she was like hyper
in a way that I was like did you have
sugar like hyper running around and
she's super calm and doesn't do anything
and then at night she goes she was
crying so she had the like hyperactivity
sugar crash and then crying saying I
can't stop thinking about chocolate like
I can't stop thinking about chocolate
and I was like that's so I was like just
you know go to sleep it'll probably be
gone in the morning but sometimes when
you eat these Foods then they get stuck
in your head
well it's unfortunate you know we have a
lot of you know and this is you know a
lot a lot of teachers and I you know I
remember when I was a kid right you get
you get a retreat for being a good kid
and students saying here's a piece of
candy and we would all do that you know
it's it's there's a lot of uh you know
if you look at Sugar as an as a drug and
some people would
don't they don't like that analogy but I
mean if it was a drug and we're saying
it's it's cheap it's legal it's
everywhere we're encouraged to to use it
and it's pretty easy to to really get
drawn into it and to become
quote-unquote addicted to it and like I
said I know people don't some people
don't like that terminology but I do see
people that really struggle with these
foods and it is tough you know because
you know you as a as a parent you can't
24 hours a day seven days a week after a
certain age you know they're going to be
off to school and there's other people
that are going to have inputs and so
it's challenging so I mean I don't know
how old she is but I know with my kids
as soon as they're old enough to kind of
comprehend us as they started to read I
would teach them you know you know food
has a role on how you feel and how your
health is and these are the things you
should try to avoid and look at look at
look at labels on packages and read
these things and see if that's something
you should probably be eating or not and
just kind of teach them that and again
you know ultimately they're going to
make their own decisions but as a parent
you know you set the example for them
they're gonna they're gonna do more what
you do than do more what you say so I
think the biggest thing is yeah well
it's setting the example in front of
them and you know you know it always
makes me laugh when a parent says well
my kid's so fussy I have to give them
goldfish in this other garbage I'm
saying there should be no situation
where a three-year-old is creating
household policy you're the you're the
adult you're the parent you know the kid
will eat what you put in front of them
at some point you know it doesn't matter
if they scream and yell you just have to
put up with it and the pro like I said
if Scarlet's never been exposed to that
garbage and you probably find a much
easier kid to deal with once you start
putting that in there oh yeah changes it
does change your behavior for sure and
and so you have yeah
step back I think you know they're
really you intervene better better off
it's going to be it's tough when you
have a kid it's 10 years old it's been
eating junk food for nine years and then
all of a sudden said guess what Junior
no more you know gummy bears and potato
chips they're gonna throw it it's gonna
be a fight so you know if you can do it
earlier that's going to be a major fight
yeah I was thinking about it last night
like I put her to bed she's just like
and I don't think it's her I I mean
she's a wonderful person but I think a
lot of it is her diet I've babysat a lot
of kids and there's I haven't been
around a kid that is this calm it was
like it's just easy going to bed is easy
eating is easy everything is super easy
and I think if you if you're worried too
about having kids if you feed them
properly they don't have these ups and
downs like you know that kid you see at
the airport and they're just like on the
ground screaming bloody murder and
you're like what's wrong with that
parent and it might be that they ate
sugar all day
and as you know I think most parents
would recognize it a bunch of sugars is
bad for the kids and you know it's kind
of funny a lot of a lot of adults even
as they discover it themselves like well
I can't eat this stuff when it's bad for
me well it's bad for your kids too and
you know you have to make that
connection and you know I think getting
the kids on board early you're not going
to do your kids any favor by making them
uh you know addicted to processed foods
and then they have some sort of uh you
know disease chronic disease mental
health disorder they're not going to
love you anymore because you fed them
lots of cake we're going to love you
more yeah and they developed as a young
as a healthy person that doesn't have
chronic diseases it feels good about
themselves so I think you just have to
realize that you know just because it's
easy to hear some sugar and placate some
for a few minutes your ultimately
long-term probably doing harm you know
if nothing else I mean skin a piece of
fruit or something like that you know
I'm not I'm not yeah kids have to be on
a Carnival diet but they need to be away
there's so much garbage out there this
build is Health you know marriage here
is an easy granola bar which is
basically processed garbage so you can
at least take the natural foods and you
know make sure they get plenty of
nutrient-dense animal Foods you know
yeah those types of things and if they
want pieces of fruit in there it's
probably no big deal once you start yeah
50 of their diet goldfish and gummy
worms and Doritos and you know security
drinks you're you're asking for trouble
for sure
mm-hmm and with Scarlett she's not on a
carnivore diet she's on a Paleo diet and
I can tell when like by her behavior and
she can tell so she's five now and she's
actually old enough to kind of look back
on her behavior and be like okay that
was a little bit weird but she's pretty
good with uh fruit now she doesn't eat a
lot of fruit and most of the fruits are
berries but she'll have pears and apples
that doesn't seem to do anything to her
mood it's really like has a tiny bit of
sugar just a tiny bit of sugar and it's
like Spike crash right even though you
could say well she ate enough berries
today that maybe the amount of sugar is
equivalent it doesn't give her the same
reaction for whatever reason right
that's the whole theoretical benefits
so ah so yeah like I said when you're
eating concentrated purely quickly
absorb sugar you're definitely going to
get a rapid change in blood glucose and
whether or not that has an effect on
mood I think one of those parents would
know I mean you can tell like I said
even come back from Grandma's house and
they at least fortunate your your
grandparents probably are not
you know your parents are probably not
feeding her a bunch of sugar but a lot a
lot of a lot of parents strong come to
Grandma's house and they come back in
their their wild child so they're crazy
you got to detox them for a couple days
yeah yeah
um have you one of the things that I
dealt with and this actually took me two
years to figure out that I was dealing
with it on the carnivore diet was what I
believe was histamine intolerance so my
my gut was really
um I probably damaged from celiac
disease and whatever else all the
medications I was on Etc and I switched
over to only eating steak and almost
everything went away and I couldn't get
my digestion under control not really
and it after about two years on the diet
and this is with my moods good
everything's good but my digestion
wasn't good I switched over to eating
lamb uh
and for whatever reason lamb sat better
and I was like what it what is that
about and then it eventually occurred to
me that a lamb is aged less and so then
I started eating just meat that was aged
less so veal and veal sat better and now
I'm back to eating beef because I love
beef like beef's my feels pretty good
too but I I really like beef and I'm
eating beef from a couple of companies
that don't age their meat and I've never
felt better but when I was doing aged
meat like I can I can't really eat out
um because it it hurts my stomach have
you seen people deal with that oh yeah
absolutely I mean there are some people
that have you know histamine reactions
in you and your point up that meet the
spinach sauces and things like that
sometimes ground beef can have a little
bit higher histamine content and so uh
absolutely you know and it's it's one of
those things depending on who you go to
for your meeting how they may hang it
and age it for several weeks typically
but some of it's very short so you can
like when I was I was just in uh uh
Bosnia over the summer for part of the
summer and we had lamb and literally it
was like the land was literally
slaughtered that morning it's the same
day yeah and it was just kind of an
interesting way that you do it in
different places that you have access to
such yeah fresh meat yeah common in the
United States are not as common
yeah in the U.S really in particular I I
went to Croatia and so one of the ways
that really solidified this like oh it's
not beef that's obsessed in my stomach
it's the aging process was I went to
Croatia and I was buying beef which was
like three dollars a pound in the local
grocery store and it was a different
color kind of than America it was like
dark red and I was like this looks like
it's going to be very difficult to eat
and it it was really good but it turns
out they they just weren't aging it they
were kind of just killing the cow and
giving it to you and I could eat that
just fine and I was like oh wow it's
it's the aging process do you think
that's an actual allergic reaction to
histamine do you know what's going on
there do you have any theories
uh well you know they're
you know we we get this histamine
response and so I mean that's
that's some history we have in our body
that's why so it's called antihistamines
are developed so uh you know I can't say
for sure because I don't think we know
what exact compound is is leading to
that
um you know there's things called die I
mean oxidase Inhibitors dnao that uh
will Advocate as a supplement to help
with this stuff but I don't know that
it's been well characterized I still
haven't seen I just see people that do
better when they switch off AIDS meet
and I was also in Croatia so I was just
gonna say that we went to Dubrovnik and
spent some time yeah that's where I was
that's fine for sure
uh my mom so my mom was diagnosed with
lupus while my family's like crazy I
don't know it's amazing that we're all
still alive at this point but that's
credit towards diet but my mom was
diagnosed with lupus and she still has
dry eyes so she uses drops but she
doesn't have any arthritis or any other
other symptoms on the diet she's been
using D because she had major histamine
issues worse than me she's had celiac
disease for years as well and she
started using Dao and that helped her
digestion the other thing that she's
been using um was low dose Naltrexone
which has also helped her digestion but
she was quite like a couple years ago
she had she had kidney cancer and like
she's been she's been through the ringer
but she's on the diet and with the diet
and low-dose Naltrexone and this date
Dao for histamine issues
um she's doing really well like better
than she has been I tried taking
low-dose Naltrexone because I've I've
constantly tried to reduce my
sensitivity so I can reintroduce Foods
or at least so that if I go out to eat I
don't
accidentally get hit with something and
I'm out for a week which is really
inconvenient and I couldn't tolerate
low-dose Naltrexone it didn't make me
feel good like none of these things make
me feel good but they worked for here
worked for her
yeah it's interesting I mean you know we
know that you know Naltrexone is
typically used for opioid uh overdose I
mean that's what you give to somebody
that's and so it does have an effect on
a lot of these receptions which
initially you know have an effect in the
gut so I'm not like I said it's not
something that I've
had a lot of experience with Naltrexone
but I don't I'm not surprised by that
it's good for her and it's good to see
your your whole family has sort of come
through the worst of it as now it looks
like they're doing it really sounds like
they're doing pretty well right now
oh yeah fantastic doing great uh Dad's
doing amazing like he's off of
everything he has been for a while so
he's touring around and has like endless
energy uh like uh it's crazy actually
the amount of energy that man has
um but it was really he needs the energy
to fight this place again so oh I know
he does it's good it's good he has it
but um he had it was just getting him
off of the um
d the psychiatric medications it was
just awful and I talked to so many
people that are just like dying getting
off of these things is brutal I'm glad
you're through we're through it got
through it and hopefully we'll just
continue to progress and continue to
stay healthy yeah
here here's a theory okay so like I said
I'm constantly trying to reduce
sensitivities and trying to figure out
exactly what's going on here's a recent
Theory I've had that I'm giving a test
and I'll keep you updated on how it goes
but I'm I moved to Tennessee
um I moved to Tennessee and you can see
by previous podcast ads my face is Puffy
my tree allergies were crazy in
Nashville and
um
really like crazy enough that I was
starting to feel like I was getting ill
constantly so I had bronchitis I was
tired all the time my face was puffy and
I started getting joint pain and I was
like what is going on uh is this from
the tree allergies like just systemic
inflammation from tree allergies
um I had asthma like it it wasn't good
um and Tennessee has really terrible
triologies and I moved and solved that
but I'm wondering if um I'm so allergic
to the environment because I've got like
food allergies and I'm allergic to
everything that grows outside I'm
wondering if the reason I have such
hypersensitivity to all plant Foods is
cross-reactivity from
different types of pollen
I mean it's interesting I mean because
you know those those same plants have
some some similar compounds you know
there's so there's some that are common
to many plants so so it could be a bit
you know constant exposure to these
things could have sensitize you
do other things that are that are also
found in plants so that I mean I suppose
that's realistic now you moved out of
Tennessee or are you are you still in
Tennessee
yeah well Scarlett was getting
bronchitis all the time too and then I
had her allergies tested and she has
like terrible allergies as well and I
was like why would I be living in
Nashville if I work online if I don't
have to so I'm in Miami now which is
fantastic I'm not allergic to palm trees
so I was in Florida this weekend I was
on the other side of the state I was
near uh Tampa so I think I have to come
to Miami November so okay well good for
you it's a nice Point yes it's
definitely this it's lovely you were in
Toronto before right so you got a huge
change in the weather for sure
yeah but so much better I felt like I I
was um actually I haven't had my vitamin
D tested in a long time I'm gonna do a
whole panel after like five years of
carnivore just to see just to see and to
show people that I'm not dying um but I
living in Canada was rough I felt it in
the winter time so it's pretty nice to
live somewhere where there's Sun as the
rest of your family moved to are they
still up again
they're still up in Canada but they're
going to be spending the majority of
their time in Florida now I've convinced
them it's like it's nice and it's sunny
why wouldn't you be here hey my tedx
talk I don't know if you know this I did
a tedx talk just about my experience and
then they wouldn't publish it and I put
it on YouTube and it has like 3.5
million views or something did you know
that Isn't that cool I remember you
saying that they refused to show it I
thought it was just you know obviously
it's nonsense so we have this sort of uh
and I you know I keep getting censored
and you know Shadow band and stuff just
because they don't I don't oh my gosh no
actually about the shadow Banning okay
so I wanted to invite you on
um to talk to you because of the five
year on the carnivore diet thing and I
was typing your name into Instagram
and because usually when people are like
oh I've been Shadow band I'm like yeah
but have you been Shadow banned or do
people just not like your posts anymore
I'm not sure if it's real Shadow Banning
and I couldn't type your name in like
long enough I had to type your entire
name in to press on your username
yeah it is it is it's kind of ridiculous
well they you know it's the stuff that
they say is problematic it's just
ridiculous I mean I posted something
about the world economic Forum which was
purely a satirical post it was just like
you know how in 2030 we're going to be
eating all these you know bugs and
upcycled humans it was clearly satire
and they said well that's misinformation
like it's satire it's meant to be funny
and they're saying it's misinformation
therefore we're gonna you know we limit
your reach apparently and so it's it's
it's it's it's kind of crazy I mean wow
I thought I was hoping after the coven
nonsense went away uh we would stop
doing this but there it's just in the
agenda the climate change uh the you
know the the you know Save the Planet
eat the bugs you know if you go if you
oppose that you know there's people who
don't like it and they just want to
continue to limit who you can get this
information to the nice thing is it's
getting out there anyway it's Grassroots
people are finding out yeah they're
never going to stop it because so many
people are out there you know you can't
SWAT a million mosquitoes you knock down
a few few people but there's just too
many people that know about this stuff
now thankfully for all of us that have
got and shared the message and I
encourage everybody to let people know
about this because it is so important
yeah but the shadow man it's it's a you
know it's it's sad to see the the you
know discussion being shut down you know
there are a lot of people I disagree
with but I would never say they
shouldn't be allowed to have a platform
or a voice you know I don't care what
you what you're talking about I mean I
don't know I think freedom speech is one
of the tenets upon which previous
societies are
uh you know are based upon and once we
start losing that we go into a very very
scary place
yeah yeah and social media can be very
helpful for people even just from a
health perspective like the groups you
can be a part of and the people you can
be you can be support that you don't
have in real life I mean I mean
literally you know I mean I've seen now
tens of thousands of people that have
literally dramatically improved their
quality Life by just you know some of
the information I've shared and so many
other folks and so to shut that down
that's really a disservice to all those
people and potentially to millions and
millions of people you know like for
instance if I would never been allowed
to speak or somebody else you never
found out about it you'd still be you
know with a horrible joint pain and all
these other things going on and maybe no
no I would have dropped it I would have
dropped the salad and I think I think
like six weeks I was getting a lot of
but I had already been there I was at
like chicken wings meat and lettuce and
at some point I would have been like
that's it I'm going to one variable and
just reintroducing back in but I was
scared and I was getting a lot of um
push back from my in-laws about like
child abuse it was very unpleasant it
was like oh you're already not eating
enough like are you producing enough
breast milk it was really aggressive and
I think that combined with the anxiety
caused by the autoimmunity I was like I
don't know gotta keep this lettuce well
and this is a science you know because
so many people don't know this you know
they all they're doing is you know sort
of parroting what they think is correct
and unfortunately that's
you know that's wrong and you end up
kind of uh you know doing things that
you you know later regret I mean because
obviously you know Scarlett is healthy
and happy and doing well and she was
clearly fed well and she's clearly
thriving at least from what I can see
when you share stuff about her on your
social media but uh you know we've got a
lot of people that are
continuing to be misinformed and
unfortunately the sort of mainstream
media likes to continue to push this
information out there you know again if
you look at every single major media
Corporation they have somebody for me to
perform on this on their reported
records so we've got this concept wow
you need to be medicated and support
the lifestyle that is conducive to being
medicated so for this um environmental
allergy crossover cross reactivity thing
theory that I have at the moment I'm
going to try
um sublingual immunotherapy so you can
kind of desense your desensitize
yourself to environmental allergens by
exposing your immune system you know how
that works
um because the even just the triology
component uh is so like it's so bad that
I'll get asthma if I go through a
neighborhood with like oak trees which
means traveling I'm like when's the
asthma attack going to happen which can
be very unpleasant I ended up actually
in the emergency room in Austin so this
is crazy and a lot of people I've seen
go on the diet their environmental
allergies improve
um but I was taking prescription
strength antihistamines and
immunosuppressants for like 10 years so
I was already near anaphylaxis near
anaphylactic towards trees and so I'm
still allergic to them but I'm going to
try the immunotherapy and see if that
reduces my overall sensitivities which
would be interesting anyway if there's a
cross reactivity thing going on because
but you are right on I see a lot of
people the opposite happens
and yeah they get better and you're able
to have people allergic to cat dander
and other things it's fine hey I don't
have those issues anymore so it is
interesting yeah that you're having so
sort of well maybe you've always been
allergic to this it's not worse oh it's
definitely not worse like I remember
when I was when I was 19 I was having
bad seasonal allergies and I was on
immunosuppressants and antihistamines
and I went to the doctor and I had my
allergies tested and she was like oh
you're like you're really allergic to
trees
um you should probably wear a mask in
goggles for like the months the summer
months it was like the spring you're
allergic to this and in the summer and
in the fall there's Ragweed and there's
mold so like I recommend a mask in
goggles I was like 19 I was like I if I
need to wear a mask and goggles to go
outside just kill me I'm like not meant
to be around so I was already who like I
was already super allergic so I'm not
that surprised that I'm still allergic
but uh I don't have symptoms of
autoimmunity or like depression or
chronic fatigue or any like rashes or
anything so life is good well I mean
you're still looking at your face and
you didn't look healthier I mean you
just got this sort of you know where you
just you can just tell you look
healthier than you did it even five
years ago so it's kudos to you yeah
you're doing that you know no
yeah not being under chronic stress has
helped too like taking care of my dad
was pretty stressful so I had a rough
patch there even on the diet stress can
um like I said the bite is important but
there's other factors that do still
believe upon your health and you you
mentioned chronic stress is a huge one
and it's important and so there's
there's other things bite is huge it's
important so you can't Overlook that but
you know there's other things that still
occur in life still happens and so but
being more resilient being able to um
you know bounce back and fight through
those things a lot easier when you when
you've got to get nutrition sure
yeah um how old are you if you don't
mind me asking I am uh 55 I seem to turn
56. so I'm still you know
hanging in there I guess I I
was you know from for people to ask him
I've had my heart scanned at zero zero
evidence of any heart disease you know
I'm still performing at a world-class
level as an athlete you know a lot of
things I'm doing that's I mean back in
Jiu Jitsu and last night I was rusting
with the 270 pound division one college
wrestler
that's so cool from that today but you
know that's that that's okay but I can
still do it you know that's a nice thing
I think the diet has helped me uh
enormously in the ability to continue to
to feel and perform good even though I'm
you know kind of an older guy at this
point but I I tend to think that you
know a lot of the a lot of the deals
with this sort of common beliefs around
aging that we're just gonna all we're
going to get fat and have joint pain and
you know all these types of things we
see that's all mostly unnecessary I mean
I think there's there's some in it I
think so many people are prematurely
aged and obesity is one of the biggest
signs of premature aging and that's what
happened to you your system is put under
so much stress and
so gosh I am I'm just very thankful I
found this you know I did I found it
when I was almost you know my late 40s
which you know if I I found it at your
age and you know in your 20s or I think
you're in your 20s when you found that
you know you just have so many better
years of quality of life which is which
is really
yeah well I honestly don't think I would
be around if I hadn't found diet like I
went to the paleo diet in 2015 and I was
on like seven medications and I was like
keeping myself alive with like Adderall
well you know like an immune
suppressants and antihistamines and I
and my joints were disintegrating and I
think if you're at the point where your
joints are like oh is my wrist gonna go
like next year like if you're at that
point I don't know how much longer you
have like I don't think I would have
lasted very long
so I'm thankful you know like I said I
think the you know because you mentioned
you know the Adderall and some of the
other medications affect your mental
health and I I'm not sure if you're
familiar with the work a guy named Dr
Chris Palmer who's at Harvard
and he's seen a lot of success with
ketogenic diets carnivore diets and
getting people you know off depression
bipolar disorder schizophrenia uh
interesting guy so I'm just giving you
an idea for something you may want to
reach out to okay he's a great guy he's
at Harvard he's at Harvard yeah
cool okay I will talk to him yeah there
should be
Dr Chris Palmer okay that's that's cool
yeah no it's good to talk to people
about Alternatives I mean I know they've
been using ketogenic diets to treat
epilepsy since forever but then they
came up with anti-epileptics and that's
like oh it's a pill it's a lot easier
than restricting yourself and there's
all the side effects and turns into a
zombie and all those other things at
least
yeah medicines too so yeah yeah it's
it's it's exciting times I think there's
a lot of people that are waking up to uh
the fact that nutrition assets too well
that's why you know the company the
timing of the company as well and again
a lot of people again there's a lot of
people questioning things you know like
like I mentioned earlier you know with
the uh of the pandemic a lot of people
are just questing whether we're being
led the right way so I think I think in
that effect of that is good more people
are sort of realizing that there's other
things out there that they should
perhaps be pursuing
yeah okay
Dr Sean Baker uh if people are trying to
find you online even though you're
Shadow banned where should they go well
I mean so Twitter you know I'm on
Twitter S Baker MD you can find me there
I'm not Shadow Man there I'm on YouTube
I got a YouTube channel Sean Baker MD
um I I've got a tick tock challenge I'm
almost embarrassed to say but it's also
Sean Baker MD and then my my Instagram
which is my largest account is is
currently being shadow man so you can
find me you have to type in my full name
Sean
baker1967 you basically have to type the
whole damn thing and find me right now
yeah hopefully we can get that shadow
man lifted or I made a start I may have
to start a new page
I'm kind of a pain if I do but whatever
I mean you just have to kind of keep
fighting the fight fighting the good
fight to get information out there
because I know we're helping people and
kudos for you and Michaela for being
willing to continue to talk about this I
know you don't have to at this point but
um you know I mean you're it's literally
saving lives and helping people so so
thanks for having me thanks for having
me on the opportunity and continue doing
what you're doing and give my best to
your family and fight a good point thank
you well thanks for doing what you're
doing too uh the reason I the reason I
started the podcast and I've said this
before but I was like this diet I'm like
I'm very thankful for this diet like
this diet saved me and I was living in
hell for a very long time
um and so I was like how do you how do
you get more people to learn about a
diet I was like okay maybe I'll start a
podcast but I won't I won't focus on the
diet I'll just like talk about the diet
every like six or seven months so that
it can grow but I'm not gonna like
alienate people from being in this weird
little like Niche carnivore so that's
the long term goal just spread this
around save people it's great to see you
be successful and I wish you continued
growth and
on and on and like I said I think at the
end of the day good will Triumph
approval so thank you
thank you well thank you for what you do
too thank you very much for coming on
[Music]